Russia's foreign minister says previous
relations with the West will not be
resumed at a news conference sege lavrov
said Western Powers had a real chance to
avoid the conflict in Ukraine but they
rejected Russian proposals to Halt NATO
expansion the West says Russia's
proposals before the Ukraine war were
insincere
let's get more on this we can speak to
Muhammad Val in Moscow Muhammad what
else did lavrov have to say
this model basically he com he focused
on Russia's reaction to the fact that
Russia was not invited to this meeting
today of the osce in Poland Russia and
Belarus he basically interpreted that as
a reckless policy by the Europeans to
ostracize Russia to Australia from the
security framework of Europe and he said
it is a mistake because your the osce
was basically you know
founded on the principle of a United
European security and that the division
of the Europeans at this stage is is
like playing with fire and he said that
that's because the United States has
turned the osc into a marginal or
irrelevant organization because it wants
to keep Russia out of of any uh of any
uh of any United policies in this regard
and that's basically because in his
words the United States wanted to
keep Russians or Europeans enslaved to
its own demands or to its own policies
and intentions also he talked about the
expansion of NATO saying that it is
wrong and it is very dangerous and it is
a threat a direct threat to the Russian
interests and the Russian security
saying NATO was founded principally as a
defensive organization and there were
terms and and and you know agreements
that bind NATO not to turn itself into
an offensive body security body but
that's not what's taking place now that
Russia by adding some of the Nordic
countries to its organization has got
got closer and closer to the Russian
territory and thus playing with faradi
as he said he even talked about the
Russian intervention the NATO
intervention in far-flung regions like
the South China Sea and that's why
Russia has now increased its cooperation
with China in order to to stand in the
face of this aggressive
expansion across the world by by NATO he
also talked about the nuclear weapons
and he said that nuclear Powers should
make sure that nuclear war doesn't take
place because that's going to be the end
of everything and he said Russia is
engaged to those principles not to uh
not to allow any any such uh thing to
happen and that the Europeans also the
Americans should take that into
consideration he talked as he said about
about the the the prospects of a kind of
solution or a kind of peace with Europe
and he said that for him now it can't be
business as usual again with Western
countries because they're not responding
to any Russian demands and and terms uh
in in order to sit for negotiations and
that's because their intent on defeating
Russia in in its war with Ukraine
Muhammad Val there for us in Moscow
thank you